tomorrow right Chaos on Capitol Hill no
seriously lawmakers acting more like
professional wrestlers by hurling
insults threats and even kidney punches
let's start with the alleged fiscal
altercation between house Congressman
Tim bersett and Kevin McCarthy bersett
was one of the eight Republicans who
voted to Al McCarthy from the speaker
seat and bashet claims McCarthy walked
by him during an interview and did this
yeah he just elbowed me in the kidy is
all he did you know it was deliberate it
was just a it just a cheap shot by a
bully it it's one of those deals that
you know you don't you just don't expect
that kind of thing from an adult
especially the guy that was at one time
a third person in line for the White
House okay no I did not elb him no I
would not elb him I would not hit him in
a kidney I guess our elbow sit as I
walked
by that's not only the only
Congressional cage match a fist fight
nearly breaking out in the Senate of all
places Republican senator Mark Wayne
Mullen trying to fight a Teamsters Union
boss who had been taunting him
online you want to run your mouth with
we can be two consenting adults we can
finish it here okay that's fine perfect
you want to do it now I'd love to do it
right now well stand your butt up then
you stand your butt up oh hold stop it
is that your solution every no no sit
down sit down you know you're a United
States Senator I'm a guy from Oklahoma
first in Oklahoma you don't do this
maybe you run your mouth in New Jersey I
don't know I'm not I'm not from New
Jersey but this is some Thug that's a
mob boss in 2022 he said he wanted to
bring the mob mentality back to the
teamsters maybe that's true but you
still not going to run your mouth at me
and expect me to just sit there I
imagine that Mullen was maybe just
fulfilling everyone's dream of anyone
who's not been a keyboard Warrior
against you and then you see them in
person and you want to fight them I know
that happens to you pretty regularly
right Harold these guys are clowns um
it's embarrassing to watch um Bernie
Sanders may get nominated for the Nobel
Peace Prize for what what he did there
this guy was I can understand your
emotions getting the better of you for a
moment or getting the worse of you but
he followed it back up on shows this
Mark Wayne Mullen fell is saying that
he's from Oklahoma first and you're not
going to criticize him or attack what
have what have our politics become when
a sitting United States Senator can't
control himself not once not twice but
three or four times even since then and
the the situation with Tim Burkett and
and Kevin McCarthy I mean grow up or go
home I mean this is they're still
talking about being elbowed or being
pushed I mean this this is not third and
fourth and fifth and sixth grade this is
United States Congress and it's
it's embarrassing Jesse what would you
have done if Greg elbowed you in the
kidneys Greg I don't think he could
reach my
kidneys that hurt the the Senate was so
proud that they have a dress code and
then they start challenging each others
to a fight I I changed my mind at first
I thought this was legit this Thug
Teamster guy he was talking a lot of
trash the guy just stood up and he's a
UFC guy or he was a mixed martial artist
he's undefeated Kevin M said he trains
he boxes with this Senator and he's not
allowed to hit Kevin in the face because
you know and but Kevin's allowed to hit
him anywhere and and one time he hit
this guy in the nose who was bleeding
got a broken nose but it was bleeding
they had to stop it because there was
blood um but Kevin is confident Kevin
now says that if he had hit him he would
have been on the ground so at first I
thought you know maybe maybe Kevin was
lying to me when he said he didn't do it
and now he's saying it was a really
tight hallway and maybe he hit him with
a shoulder but I now I don't really like
the way burett reacted oh and I'm
thinking burett seems a little soft and
I don't like to say other men are soft
because I don't know burett and I need
to keep good relations with these people
because they have to come on my show but
he was on my show last night and I wish
I had called him not not a a wimp or
anything but the way he handled it
wasn't really the best way to handle it
okay okay judge we also know that there
have been on the on the feminine side of
the aisle I guess I would say that
you've had um cat fights so to speak of
the words going back and forth but no
fistic cuffs yet yeah well you know we
we kind of went from a speaker fight to
a budget fight now we're down to a fist
fight but here's the thing you know the
comment that you made about the elbow is
very important because Kevin McCarthy
seems to be about the same height as
this guy brette okay and if he's gonna
elbow him in the kidneys first of all
he'd have to go like that to get down to
his kidneys I mean it's something that
you could solve forensically but there
there are a bunch of wusses I mean very
detective it's very easy to resolve this
thing and you know what this guy if
you're G to run your mouth let's do it
outside you know we don't want to hear
that it's like the downfall of the
United States I mean everything is
falling down even in Congress you know I
thought we really reach and
sophisticated stuff when we said that
that uh uh fetman had to wear a suit or
at least look you know like he he was
respecting the office of Senate and now
they're down to fistic cups they're
ridiculous and men are just maybe too
much testosterone careful judge it's not
don't you dare speak in generalities
about my gender all right I will too
much testasterone there's four of them
we just proved it let's settle this
right now yeah do you think that uh John
krey should bring James Taylor over for
a little kumbai it's about it's about
time but I think Mullen was lucky that
it was that Union boss and not Randy
weard
she is she's a Bruiser I got Randy on
that one she's Gary Shandling with human
growth hormone you ever noticed that now
that you mention it but I you know what
I don't mind this at all I mean I think
this is the kind of political story we
need because it's essentially harmless
it's it's like think about think about
the conflicts that are going on in the
Democratic party right now they can't
agree on whether beheading children
deserves a response you know what I mean
they're you know they're calling each
other names they're eling each other kid
I'll take that that's not a real Rift
you know at the end of the day they
still agree on the basic moral
principles that you know an atrocity
occurred on October 7th you know what
and also uh I mean they weren't really
GNA I mean if Bernie can break up a
fight there was no fight Bernie hold me
back yeah Bernie hold me back let me get
your jacket if they're fighting at least
they're not raising your taxes that is
true d That's Point hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else